a couple of things right I don't want
notation which we explained by a further
definition because I actually haven't
given you a formal definition yeah just
show you pictures you will notice
degrees have a symbol the circle right
because rotations about circles okay I
have not written any symbols for radians
right which you would think is a good
idea because when you convert between
units if I said you know one meter is a
hundred centimeters you kind of need
units on both sides right does that make
sense because it's like well if you said
one equals a hundred centimeters you'd
say one what like you need the unit
there is a unit symbol for radians okay
it looks like this I know that looks
like a C but it's actually an incomplete
circle like it's a major arc in a circle
because that symbol looks so much like a
degree symbol right when people are
writing right in today what it'd be
ended ambiguous honestly they'll write
this okay in the past when I have wanted
to indicate I'm definitely talking about
radians not talking about degrees or
anything else I will always prefer this
over this I just think you're asking for
yeah okay no let me get to that you will
notice even though I have these two
options I have used neither of them and
that was very deliberate and that's for
two reasons okay number one it is
implied right if you're talking about
ankles right and you haven't put a
degree symbol on there by the way this
is one of the reasons why when you first
learn a trick I heard you know it was
really a big deal but you said sine 30
degrees and not just sine 30 even if you
say sine 30 it's really important you
put the degrees on there because that's
indicating how you measure if you saw
sine PI on six right
clearly I'm putting angles into the
steak and it is quite clearly like what
else would that be like I'm locking PI
on six because PI is about 3.14 right so
pilot six would be about 0.5 3.5 or
whatever it is okay
oh wait five four degrees five two
degrees zero point five two degrees
that's an interesting angle not okay so
clearly you are implying in two areas
but there's a more fundamental reason
there's a more fundamental reason
radians are in fact despite the way I've
been saying it all this time to help you
understand radians are in fact not a
unit this is really weird
they're what we call a dimensionless
quantity and I will try and now explain
for you in my formal definition for what
radians are why they are dimensionless
quantity why they actually I'm not used
at all in fact they're the opposite of
use so you need to draw yourself a new
circle for simplicity safely but
simplicity say what I did was I am I
started with the unit circle
yeah the unit circle and so the
circumference of the unit circle is 2 pi
and halfway around the circumference of
the unit circle is pi and so on okay but
um you know me a pretty lousy measure of
angles if the only circles you can
measure in the unit circle
okay now this is not a problem because
every circle because of the shape of the
circle every circle is similar similar
to every other circle in existence
they're all similar to each other yes
they're just different in scale but they
are the same micro shape basically okay
so therefore if I extend it if I do
imagine a circle of arbitrary radius not
just radius one how do i extend my
definition of radians or rather an
extender you know proper definition
radius that works over here okay now
keep in mind I still want a full
revolution a full revolution to be two
pi radians okay two pi what the
circumference of this circle is not
supplying what is this a compass in to
say it's to my operate all the way
around is two pi off now how can I get
two pi out of but there are only two
feet
is the radius and there's a
circumference okay well clearly can you
see that two pi that's the angle that
I'm interested how does it connect how
is it related to the circumference
that's been traced out and the radius
which is the size of the circle okay now
the answer it is the actual size of the
angle the two pi it's the ratio right
it's the ratio between the circumference
that's been traced out and this size of
the radius of the circle that I'm in
okay radians are the ratio between
however long this arc is in this case
it's the whole circle that's why it's
the circumference between the arc length
and the radius of the circle I mean the
reason why this is great is because it
catches it catches the size of the
circle built in right you can make your
radius one or a hundred or a quarter or
anything you like and this radius and
this circumference will still be in the
same ratio right because that's what it
means for shapes to be similar their
lengths are in the same proportion
okay now ratios don't have units right
like if I said three centimeters to five
centimeters right this I would write a
ratio okay but really this is the
fraction three centimeters on five
centimeters right but it's a ratio it's
just three over five he doesn't care if
you're talking in centimeters or meters
or kilometers all light-years right the
ratio is still the same number and it's
just a number there are no units
attached to this ratio okay
and being that radians are ratios just
like this is a ratio hence they are
dimensionless just the number okay and
that's why I'm not writing even though I
have them I'm not going to write it from
now on a symbol to indicate radians I'll
say it okay I will read this out as pi
radians equals a hundred eighty degrees
but I'm not going to write it because
that's really what's going on
there's not really a unit happy the
absence of you
now I've kind of been alluding to this
but hopefully I can show to you on this
diagram make it really really clear
radians it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to see that this is connected
to the word radius why is it connected
to the word radius well have a look have
a look at what would happen if this is
2pi around okay what would happen like
what is I know what two pi radians are
and on pi readings are two truck
what's one radio what is like how big is
one Radian okay now you will find out if
you want if you go into here and you you
take this guy and you say well if I want
to make one on the left hand side I
would divide by PI that would get me one
on left hand side so one Radian would be
a hundred and eighty on PI degrees right
now if my memory says I think you'll
find that's a few 47.2 three to nine
fifty seven point three degrees and
you're like but you want to be you want
to be like all you don't wanna be random
and arbitrary you want to be something
that's built into the mathematical
nature answer nothing the reason why
it's nothing is cuz I've written in
degrees right that's the problem come
back over here fifty-seven point three
degrees I want you to try and estimate
if you were to draw an angle like here's
my two pi radians if you an estimate to
draw an angle of Pi one Radian which is
fifty seven point three views about when
it goes fifty seven point three it is
pretty really that's exactly right
nearly halfway between half between 45
and 60 nearly halfway halfway to what
notes are right angles we have an
intuitive sense of what a right angle
looks like yes
fifty-seven point three is like more
than half of a right angle yes more than
half a right angle so I'm going to
roughly estimate
there this is one radio okay now when
you look at this one Radian how does it
connect all of these pieces together
right
well if radians are the ratio between
the arc length and the radius yes and if
the particular a number of radians I'm
interested in is one what ratio is the
number one like this is the ratio of
three to five what ratio is the number
one it's um it's one to one
not one to one means my two quantities
are the same size right what two
quantities am i talking about yet
I'm talking about the radius and the
onclick that guy there right that's the
arc length it's been traced out by one
Radian do you see it can you even see I
heard my diagram is good enough right
does that I click not look exactly the
same length as the radius right to go
one Radian wrote in rotation means to go
one radius around the circumference
right and how many radii can I go ends
up did you buy it right but that's how
many I can do all the way around the
circle yeah it sure is
right radians are so much a superior way
to measure angles because they're baked
into the waste circles are right so this
is the key idea what that implies is
that one Radian is the angle that traces
or cuts out and arc equal to the radius
of the circle
okay fifty-seven point three it is it
does sound random the reason sounds
random is cuz degrees of random right
radians are awesome if you go around one
Radian you've gone one radius around the
circumference I wouldn't be surprised
though if it wasn't necessarily before
or after because completely different
groups of people what these are these
different measurements you see these
different schemes okay
engineers mathematicians and I mean like
mathematician mathematicians because if
you want to do calculus involving angles
you have to you have to do this you must
use as you will discover next year
degrees I don't know like well sailors
and therefore everyone else who
inherited the aimless system that they
introduced to us